TURNS 29 FORKING COULDLYN PIETRO
AND THE SPEED FINISH. WASHINGTON
FRONT.
COULDN'T GET HIM THE.
SEND SCHEIFELE AWAY FOR STASTNY.
LEAVE FOR WHEELER.
IT OPENS  THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE,
AND TURNS.
>> Dennis: JETS LOOKING FOR
MORE. AND
FIND LOOSE OFF A STICK, AND
SCHEIFELE WILL SEND IT AHEAD FOR
SHOT BLOCKED.E, SCORES.
GOOD DEFENSIVE PLAY AND A
BOUNCING PUCKSER--
SHOT, SCORES!
[air sirens]
[C[CHER ONE AND TIGHTOSE.
STANLEY CARRIES IT LOW. START FS
TEAM.
HE GETS AND ASSIST ON THE KYLE
26 MINUTES AND 40 SECONDS.
NICE JOB GETTING CONTROL OF THAT
PUCK ON ENTRY P
POINTS.
>> Kevin: YEAH. NHLers.
UP TOP FOR PIETRANGELO.
PUCK, AND EVERYBODY WITH HIM,
CHOPPED AROUND THE BOARDS. SVECT
THEY'VE BEEN IN AND AROUND THE
NET.
30 SHOTS FACEOFF.
MORRISSEY TEES THIS ONE UP AND
DADONOV.
NATE SCHMIDT SEND IT DOWN THE
ICE.GET THE PUCK TO GO FIVE HOL.
THAT IS A PATENT MOVE COGHLAN.
UNDER TWO-AND-A-HALF TO GO HERE
IN THIS ONE.
WINNIPEG JETS LOOK